a year ago today I left my family my  friends and countless female admirers to  come to Russia a place that is cold  miserable and where I couldn't speak the  language to say and may your success  continue through the coming year being  reported kidnapped after a ransom note  was found on a Russian officials door  you come from a big American Church on  the round town telling people he loves  everybody did you love me  trying to cooperate with them whatever  you want will get you money my food  passports anything just just tell us  the president pledged full support of  efforts to bring the missionaries to  safety no ransom will be made losing my  patience our mission is over  perfect we get one shot at this we have  about a one in a million chance of  surviving here I want to be alive to  take that chance  you pray for my family  you